de los últimos discursos a que hemos
escuchado ha sido el larguísimo discurso
del presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
quien además en estos momentos está
dando más declaraciones todavía a la
prensa Y seguramente entre las preguntas
que le van a caer va a ser la ausencia
de referencias al tema de El Salvador y
es que recordemos que en las últimas
semanas ha lanzado muchas críticas
contra el presidente salvadoreño y
contra su oplana de seguridad extrema y
su estado de excepción que dura ya un
año sin embargo sí que Gustavo Petro ha
hecho referencia a condenado la
situación Eso sí en Perú ha dicho que
cómo vamos a celebrar que Venezuela
regrese al sistema
interamericano de derechos humanos y que
al mismo tiempo no condenemos
literalmente que un presidente que
debería estar aquí esté en prisión
preventiva en referencia a Pedro
Castillo otra de las cuestiones que ha
destacado Petro ha sido la necesidad una
vez más de cambiar el paradigma de la
guerra contra las drogas ha señalado que
esta guerra no lanzada por Estados
Unidos hace ya 50 años ha cargado no ha
acabado con un millón de Vidas
latinoamericanas y ha propuesto la
capital de Colombia Bogotá como sede
para una reunión latinoamericana para
abordar una cuestión que dice ya no es a
colombiana sino que es americana y
mundial entre otras condenas que hemos
escuchado ha sido la de la presidente
chileno Gabriel borich a lo que ha
llamado La dictadura familiar de Daniel
Ortega en Nicaragua ha dicho que el
mundo que latinoamérica no se puede
quedar callada ante esta situación
recordemos que Daniel Ortega no se
encuentra en la Cumbre sino que está
representado por su canciller ha dicho
también en relación al hecho de que
Nicaragua haya quitado la nacionalidad
unos 300 a ciudadanos que sabe bien
Daniel Ortega que la nacionalidad la
patria se lleva en el alma se puede
quitar por decreto entre otras menciones
que han hecho los presidentes
latinoamericanos que han hablado Por el
momento Luis Arce por ejemplo ha hablado
de la necesidad de separar la hoja de
Coca del estigma que acarrea para la
producción de otras sustancias y por
ejemplo Guillermo lasso el presidente de
Ecuador ha sido alguno de los que ha
condenado públicamente la invasión rusa
de Ucrania una cuestión que recordemos
según al borrador al que hemos tenido
acceso no figura en la declaración de
Santo Domingo como